this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
minimalists
hello simpletons welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan we all want
friendship in our lives
yes so we accumulate scores of friends
you have scores of friends well we
collectively
oh okay it's scores of acquaintances and
co-workers and partners and lovers and
companions and contacts and colleagues
and
associates but in time we realize that
relationship clutter
is getting in the way of loving
meaningful connections
so today we're going to talk about
decluttering
friendships ryan i'm going to need four
men and 100 bibles for this episode
oh that poor guy you and i were at a
coffee shop
last year well two years ago now last
year didn't count right yeah they shut
down
didn't they i don't i think they're in
the pandemic they probably did metro
cafe on santa monica
and this guy walks in off the street
this beautiful
manic homeless man uh who is just this
ball of
like light and energy and he walks up to
the front counter you want to explain
what he said
yeah so josh and i were ordering some
coffee which by the way this place it's
pay what you want which is amazing
it's a non-profit so you can literally
pay nothing or i will always overpay
because i'm like it's a non-profit right
yeah yeah it's a great
it's a great concept um and it was
working until the pandemic but anyway so
we're sitting there ordering coffee and
this man comes in
and he looks at one of the baristas and
he's like i think i figured it out
and he's like really man cool what'd you
figure like you know we're just being
nice though what'd you figure out man
he's like
all i need are four men and 100 bibles
he's like he's like give me four men and
a hundred bibles
and we're going to the park
and and a piece of me wanted this like
there was a love in this man yeah
that that now i i don't want to approach
the world the same way as him but that's
okay too
right yeah but there was this love that
he was emanating
and so i kind of want that to be the
theme of today because we're going to be
talking about decluttering friendships
it's not an unloving
thing that we're talking about what
we're talking about
is how to love someone sometimes even
from
a distance and it's most loving when we
prioritize
our relationships yeah i hear one of us
is recently vaccinated
does that mean we can still be friends i
i i don't know i guess it's up to
my friends
[Laughter]
we have a record record number of
questions today
i mean sean you did an amazing job in
fact i think the
maximal episode will be so long
that we might have to take like several
pee breaks or something
uh we have so many amazing questions
about
decluttering relationships friendships
partnerships
colleagues co-workers etc so ryan i
figured we'd just go ahead
and dive yeah right into our questions
we have one from
facebook we're at the minimalist on
facebook twitter and instagram by the
way
if you want to follow us over there
penny has a question for us
penny wrote in how can i stop feeling
pressured to keep up with
so many connections i don't want to ask
anybody
but i just don't have the time or mental
energy i have too many friends
and they have all been my friends for
almost 20 years wow those are some
long-lasting relationships there wow
there are no bad apples i've been in
everyone's weddings
most of my friends are not friends with
each other so getting everyone together
at the same time is not often a
possibility i feel
spread thin i value my time alone
into myself as well so
the thing that stands out here is how
penny feels um
she feels spread then yes and it's
possible to be
spread thin with a lot of good things
because it doesn't sound like she's
holding on any toxic relationships right
it's just she wants to hang out with
everyone i've
i've might have come across this problem
a time or two yeah i believe that so
penny's an extrovert probably or at
least even if she's not
she has been told by society what
the expectation is you accumulate
friends
and you hold on to those friends for
your entire life
as opposed to understanding that some
friendships in fact i
i think most friendships have some sort
of
expiration date in fact we're going to
talk about that a bit on the maximal
episode this thursday on
patreon some expiration date how do we
determine
if it'd be nice if when you met someone
they had like a little expiration label
on them like this relationship is good
until january 2023
that would be convenient it's
interesting living in los angeles
the big one of the biggest problems i i
face is
running across so many awesome people
there's so many amazing people in l.a
right and
you don't have time to hang out with
them all right now there are like a
handful of friends that i'll see
on a regular basis which for me is like
once
every couple months but
like in missoula it was that would have
been too long two months would have been
too long like my
friends were so local and i could see
them on a regular basis we can meet up
you know grab a quick dinner or a quick
lunches quick cup of coffee
or in la it's it's a lot harder to get
from point a to point b
yeah it's much more spread out so if you
live in pasadena and you have a friend
in malibu you're never even right
to see that they might as well live in
another state right but if i tried to
maintain my friendships in la like i did
in missoula
it would spread me too thin that's a
great point and so what you're saying
here is that
as your life changes maybe it's
geography based maybe has to do with
what you're working on creatively or
professionally at the time
or maybe you've you've started a family
and so your priorities tend to shift
and as a result the way that you
allocate your time
needs to shift as well otherwise we feel
what
spread thin yeah and and the only reason
we feel
spread thin is because we've assumed the
expectation by the way no one even told
you
that you needed to continue to spend
time with all these people because a
friend can be a friend even if you see
them once a year or once every other
year
some of my closest friends i haven't
seen in three or four or five years
i talked to them on the phone
occasionally my friend jamar who i write
about
and love people use things our new book
that comes out in
july now i i wrote
i write about him he's in cincinnati i
haven't seen him i've seen him once
in the last five years wow the last time
i saw him was at our
dayton event at press oh wow he just
showed up
so that was back in 2012. yeah that's
what maybe i mean
him and i aren't like as good a friends
as you guys but yeah i mean it's it's uh
yeah it's been a while since i've seen
him too and i talked to him on the phone
and but we live in different states
and what i've realized is it doesn't
have to be
that you know when i get when i become
friends with someone and
we're texting or talking to each other
it doesn't have to be that way forever
maybe we don't live in the same city
my favorite example of this is colin
wright one of our closest friends right
in fact one of our books so everything
that remains is dedicated to
colin and in fact we wrote the first
draft of that book right when we were
starting
uh asymmetrical press the the publishing
company that we started and we moved
into a house with colin me you and him
and we saw each other every day and talk
to each other
every day but at this point i talked to
him maybe a couple times a year you know
two
three times a year and that's okay
because
as life ebbs and flows it's not that
we're growing
a part we're not in the same city but
what is nice
because there isn't that expectation for
constant communication
when we do end up being in the same city
that time together
is so much more meaningful because it's
not peppered with
just the the sort of bland natterings of
everyday
you know teta uh with with
acquaintances not that those things are
wrong the problem is when
we expect ourselves by the way no one
else is expecting this or if they are
expecting it
don't you don't have to let someone
else's expectations
dictate how you spend your time if you
do that
you're going to feel discontented so the
real problem here is
because when i read the beginning of
this this it almost sounds like she's
bragging at first i got all these
friends i've had them for so long and
they're awesome there's no bad friends
and
it's wonderful it's like well okay but
what's the problem oh
the problem is i feel an obligation
to spend an inordinate amount of time
with these people
yeah and so it's not about even letting
go of the relationships here it's about
decluttering
the expectation the obligation that you
have thrust upon yourself
most of the pressure we feel is internal
pressure and that external pressure if
there is some of it
you don't have to you don't have to hold
on to that either yeah
yeah penny i mean there's a delta
between what she doesn't want
to ask anybody but what she does want is
to not be so
spread thin so you know there has to be
some type of
uh the only way i can think of is
reckoning but i'm not saying that
pejoratively it's reconciled yeah
there's some reconciling that needs to
happen
and penny needs to be honest like hey uh
how much time
do you need to reclaim and how can you
work
with your friends to reclaim that time
some of my favorite friendships
um like i got a friend john sweeney you
know john sweeney yeah in ireland
yeah over uh yeah over in ireland and i
see him once every
two years maybe once every three years
something like that but
when we're together we have the best
time
me and his wife and even his kids like
we
mariah and i just like have an awesome
time with their family and you don't
have to text him every day or get on
skype with him every day for that to
happen
and every time we see each other it's
like it's like we just saw each other
the day before
exactly and that that is that's a sign
of a good friendship
yeah so it's okay penny that you you
know you don't see these friends that
you really admire and really love
it's okay that you don't see them as
much as you want to i guarantee you that
if they're
really awesome friends if they're as
awesome as you say they are which i i
know they are penny
um whether you see them once a week or
once a month or once every other month i
know that you're you can still be
friends with those people and still have
just
as meaning as many meaningful
experiences
penny i'm gonna send you a copy of our
book minimalism live a meaningful life
what we're really talking about here is
re-prioritizing our relationships in
that book we talk about the three tiers
of relationships
we have primary relationships secondary
relationships
and the peripheral relationships and we
try to delineate because
unfortunately in our culture what
happens and i think this is where the
stress
comes from we'll often spend 90 percent
of our time with people in that
periphery
and there's nothing wrong with these
people actually there aren't even bad
apples here right right
but the problem is that when we do that
when
all of our time 80 or 90 of our time is
allocated with co-workers and colleagues
and acquaintances and networking buddies
you're forsaking the people closest to
you right yeah and so you're coming home
really late and it's like well i spent
all the time with the person in the
cubicle next to me
these relationships that are birthed out
of proximity and convenience
so there's an entire relationship
chapter there and what you'll realize in
that is
yeah sometimes we do have to as you say
ax some
relationship some toxic relationships
let go of toxic relationships and we'll
be talking about that a bit
on the maximal episode this thursday on
patreon but
i i do want to before we before we move
on i do want to say that maybe
we think about some different language
uh ryan said reconciling
that's a much better way to think about
it than axing the relationships or
reprioritizing
instead of axing the relationships so if
you like our podcast you'll like the
audiobook version
of minimalism live a meaningful life or
if you want the book book or the ebook
version we'll send those to you
as well you know one of the biggest
mistakes i made in the corporate world
one of the many mistakes i've made is i
really tried to be fr most of my friends
were in the corporate world they were
they
were co-workers i had some outside
friends but i really
went out of my way to like make friends
inside
inside of the corporation and it
actually hurt me in a lot of ways
um like there's a certain point where i
had to accept like oh
these people aren't going to be my
friend so i had this expectation like i
could be friends with anyone
yes but you know they have their own
lives outside of the corporation the
smart ones did
they had their own lives outside the
corporation uh they would go work and go
home where i'm like
no let's hang out and be friends but it
really it just drove me crazy and
uh it was it was just wasn't a good idea
and as you said
you had that expectation meaning you
picked it up right no one handed it to
you
and even if someone did try to hand you
that expectation
you can politely refuse it yeah which
we're also going to talk about but
brooke has a question from
instagram i've never struggled to
declutter my
friends on social media when they no
longer have a meaningful place in my
life
but how do i explain their removal when
they ask me about it without hurting
their feelings
let me ask you this ryan so i actually
like that brooke put
friends in quotation marks here right
yeah because it's almost as though we
need a new word to describe our
quote friends on social media
friends there we go that's beautiful
right because
ryan and i happen to be social media
friends but not really we're just
friends
friends right like we know each other we
spend time with each other
and i don't spend time we're literally
friends on social media
yeah we're way more friends in real life
yeah that's absolutely true right
now part of that is because you and i
don't spend very much time on social
media
right and and i think maybe the other
problem is many of us at least for the
longest time
even you and i will fit in this category
many of us don't spend much time in real
life
oh man and and so that's why we're
then drawn to the the facebook friends
or the instagram
friends and so yes there there can be
some tension
here when you unfollow someone on social
media
i've had to unfollow certain friends
recently especially when like
um the election is nearby and i see them
it's not that i
don't want them to have their own
opinion and everything else i don't i
simply don't want their opinion
thrust onto me and so quite often what
i'll do
is i'll unfollow everyone and i'll
re-follow just the people
that it makes sense to follow i'll
actually learn this from you ryan it was
a practice that you did a few years ago
yeah i uh i got that from jason zuck
okay he would he would do that so it
inspired me to
do the same thing yeah what i love about
that is when you have
when you're following zero people you
because i would still go on social media
but you really start to find out who it
is that you care about because
when i would go to twitter i'd go to
instagram i would look up specific
people like oh what are they up to and
then after a month i'm like oh okay here
are like at least the 20 people i know
that i'm checking
in on you know when i get on these
platforms so i know that i want to
follow them and then
you know sure enough i think i started
like with 20 and now you know wherever
i'm at right now on instagram i couldn't
tell you but
it's getting to the point again where
it's a little bit too much
yeah so i might do this fast again so
brooke uh
there's nothing wrong with having a a
a social media fast and ultimately i
guess i would say like brooke you don't
have to explain yourself to anyone
yeah although i'll tell you what's
messed up man so uh
deleted facebook they
didn't when someone requested me as a
friend it just says
oh you've sent a firm request to ryan
nicodemus your friend request is pending
and i've had people come up to me and
they're like why don't you accept my
friend request man
and i'm like on what and they're like
facebook i'm like i'm not on facebook
they're like oh
that makes sense but like it's almost
it's uh snapchat
when i deleted snapchat um i mean i
think i'm back on there now but
a while ago i deleted snapchat and my
brother got a message it said
uh ryan nicodemus blocked you oh wow and
he sent me a screenshot he's like dude
what's up with this
and i'm like that's messed up man like
these platforms are literally
they are creating unnecessary tension
yes so your friends can peer pressure
you into getting back on the platform
yes
it's really evil man if you think about
it i i totally agree with that and so
i mean it depends on on what the person
says to you in most cases
as ryan illustrated 99.9 of the time
the person either a won't notice at all
i would have no idea
if you unfollowed me or unsubscribed
whatever like i would have no idea i
wouldn't have i don't have any sort of
notification set up or anything like
that
or if they do notice if they love you
they will understand
yeah and so they'll understand what that
you're trying to protect your own mental
health
or if they don't understand well then
that says something about them it
doesn't say anything about you now if
someone does come up to you
as part of the you know .01 or 0.1
percent
of folks who do notice it and they are
offended and they want to say something
to you
then of course you can say oh well
obviously i don't mean
to hurt your feelings i simply
unfollowed everyone or i
i decided to do a social media detox and
so i had to unfollow
a lot of people because what i realized
is i was saying yes to social media
and it prevented me from saying yes to
what was truly important
yeah and we can tell people that here's
what i'm saying yes too when they are
asking you if you care about them you
love them like ryan said you don't owe
anyone an explanation
and you don't have to explain anything
but if someone comes up to you says hey
you hurt my feelings and you feel
compelled to have a
deep meaningful conversation with them
then talk to them
about not what you're saying no to what
am i i'm not renouncing anything
i'm saying yes to something else in
order to say yes to this
i had to let go of some of my old habits
yeah
absolutely the people who love you will
they will understand and if they don't
understand then
probably was better you don't follow
them anyway well right because
maybe you have different values in fact
brook i'm going to send you a copy of
our
new book love people use things it's not
out yep but it will be out july
13th i'll hold it up if you're watching
this on youtube
a lot of people use things because the
opposite never works it's available for
pre-sale right now so if you head on
over to lovepeopleusethings.net if
you're in the u.s
canada australia the uk ireland
several other places you can pre-order
it now it's also going to be in dozens
of languages
stay tuned to our newsletter for when
your language
comes out a lot of people use things the
values chapter in here so it's about
seven different relationships
one of those is our relationship with
our values getting really clear on your
values and also the
values of the people closest to you will
help you better
interact with those people so you don't
have to explain yourself
because explaining yourself is at the
end of sort of indiscretion
right but if you can cut it off but by
sharing
your values with other people then they
will already understand and if they
understand then it doesn't require an
explanation anyway also there's a
chapter here about people our
relationship
with people it's my favorite chapter in
the book
and in fact on the maximal episode this
week i'm going to read an excerpt from
the people chapter ryan what time is it
you know what time it is it is time for
our lightning round where we answer your
text messages
text your questions and comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed those texts go
to both of our phones during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer questions with a
short
shareable less than 140 character
response we put the text to these
minimal maxims in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place
minimalmaxims.com all right carol's got
a question what does a truly healthy
friendship look like i have a pithy
answer
for you i think let me just be clear
about this because
we have to be careful with the word
healthy quite often we use that
to say good like what is a good
relationship
and if by good you mean fulfilling
that's one thing we use good
as just sort of this placeholder word
but unfortunately we often mean good as
in like morally good
yeah and i will just say that there
aren't morally good or morally
bad relationships if someone's harming
you then they
are being you know they're create they
are creating
these immoral indiscretions and so
that's something different
but if we're talking about a healthy
relationship here's my pithy answer for
you
a healthy relationship is one that
enhances your life
without trying to change the other
person
you know we often say ryan you can't
change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
meaning
i can't say well ryan i really think
that you you should cut your arm off it
would really make me happy if you cut
your arm off right right away
and no instead it's like well i i can
start to surround myself that's really
what's going to make me happy i'm going
to have to go
search for people who have one arm right
right as opposed to trying to sever off
my best friend's
arm yeah of course that's a ridiculous
perotic exaggeration
but what it does is it illustrates a
point instead of changing
someone in my life i can surround myself
with supportive
caring people also i found this other
definition here that
that really stood out to me there's this
gal emma krebs she has a podcast called
the curious one i know about it because
bex was on her podcast recently and so
was our friend colin wright
i told her i would do episode 100 of her
podcast which i think she's about 50
episodes away from
so she has something to work toward but
the curious one podcast this is from her
instagram account at the curious one
podcast and she took a the screenshot i
think it is a reworking of dr nicole
lapera's
thoughts on relationship and here it
says relationship
noun a safe space to evolve
through life let's break that down for a
second
so a safe space to evolve through life
together so a healthy relationship
ryan's in my relationship orion and
mariah's relationship for example
it is a safe space meaning it's there is
no it's not about tension or judgment if
i'm
if i commit some sort of act or
indiscretion or error
it's not about your judgment of me if i
do need help and i
ask for help you'd be willing to help me
i know that
but it's not about changing that other
person that's what that safe space
is about evolving through life together
means that
as you change your relationship changes
as well
uh beck's on her podcast how to love and
i we're having this conversation
about there isn't really a relationship
so much as there's two people who are
constantly evolving and as we
travel on the same path together like
when you and i live with kotlin for that
year in missoula we were very closely on
that same exact path
for a year but then his path sort of
bifurcated from
hours and for a period of time but of
course
they may come back together at some
point as well
and so a relationship doesn't have a
defined
period of time it's what is going on
right now and as we
change the quote-unquote relationship
changes
as well yeah it's interesting because
that definition
has the word evolve right yes and
evolution is changing
right so you're not trying to change
someone you are
trying to support them in their changes
that's a great way to put it
uh my fifth answer is this there are
three main
ingredients in a healthy relationship
love respect and understanding
and and how to uh i'm sorry and uh love
people use things
there is a recipe in there that we have
for a healthy relationship and i think
there are eight ingredients in there
that's right so so there are certainly
more ingredients than love respect and
understanding but i know
that this is my context whenever i start
to
find myself uh
like having a having a knee-jerk
reaction or getting a little upset or
whatever it is
with with any of my relationships
romantic friendships
or even like a colleague it's like i
have to go back to okay if i want
to not if i want if i want to
de-escalate whatever's happening right
now inside of me
then i have to focus on this context of
love respect and understanding because
even when you go meet someone for the
first time you go order a coffee
you know when you're when you're talking
to the barista all they want is they
want to see that a
you respect them b that uh you know you
have some
type of understanding where they're
coming from and that you're being a
genuine
loving kind person like you can never go
wrong with that right so if if any of
those i will say if any of those three
ingredients are missing from the
relationship
it's probably not going to be maybe it
said the healthy we say meaningful it
wouldn't be a very meaningful
relationship if you're missing uh one of
those three ingredients
i i agree with that and so yeah there
are eight ingredients i'll just go
through those real quick there's a
section in
love people use things called repairing
and strengthening
relationships and it talks about the
eight
different ingredients here uh what
ryan and i pinpointed the eight elements
of great relationships
of meaningful relationships and if i
were to characterize those elements
today i'd define them as
follows and so i'm not even going to
read through all the definitions but we
have love so you mentioned that
you have trust honesty
and so trust and honesty are slightly
different that's why they're both in
here
caring support attention
authenticity and understanding and then
we
break down understanding which has like
four main ingredients respect is one of
those ingredients and that's that's sort
of the third ingredient
and i like what you say to ryan about
the three main ingredients because like
if you make your famous masaman curry
there might be three main ingredients
but there's going to be more than three
ingredients uh that are important for a
meaningful relationship yeah like the
masaman curry
actually it's it's funny uh because just
to continue the analogy
there are several ingredients just in
that curry
that have to come together right to make
the masaman curry so and that could be
like understanding so right
understanding is tolerance acceptance
respect and appreciation that's how you
truly understand
someone you you awaken to that person
when you're able to appreciate them
warts and all
right now ryan i do want you to talk
about real quick the de-escalating
because
you mentioned that if if because
de-escalating is an
important part of meaningful
relationships
so why would someone want to de-escalate
in a relationship
uh you don't always when you hear that
you don't always associate that with
relationships
yeah if you're escalating tension
or you know an argument or whatever it
is in a relationship you are
pushing that person further away and
the more you escalate the more you're
going to push which is going to lead to
uh resentment it's going to lead to
sometimes it'll lead you feeling guilty
for pushing that person away i mean it
leads to all types of negative emotions
and unfortunately it'll eventually lead
to a toxic relationship
yes so de-escalating is going to
be the hardest thing to do especially if
you're in the moment
and you're very heated and you're very
angry and you feel
disrespected it's it's very
uncomfortable
to de-escalate however in the long run
like that's going to be your best option
any time you're 99.999 of the time
uh that you know you're getting into an
argument
i want to talk about respect a little
bit because a lot of people
they have the expectation of they need
to be respected
and you know you know oh that so-and-so
was disrespect disrespect to me and i'm
gonna
you know i'm gonna disrespect them back
but the thing is is like in order to be
respected
you have to respect others that's how
you earn it that's how you're in respect
is by respecting
others you don't walk into a situation
demanding respect
and then all of a sudden you base your
actions off of whether or not that
person
is respecting you if they start to
disrespect you a little bit
if anything you should go again to
de-escalate go out of your way
to respect them because that's the only
way you're actually going to get them to
uh well understand yes where you're
coming from
i want to talk real quick about
attention as well and then we can maybe
wrap up by talking about toxic
relationships
what is a toxic relationship we can try
to define
that a bit but attention is this
fascinating thing because that is one of
the
eight elements that we we covered there
for a meaningful relationship
unfortunately it we can have misguided
attention
another way to think of attention is
focus right so if you focus on
on something you may be focusing on the
quote unquote wrong
thing of the relationship yeah someone
everyone has their quirks and foibles
and
and idiosyncrasies and your partner or
friend or family member might do one
thing that drives you
insane and if you focus on
that then you're not you're actually
getting in the way of your overall
awareness of the person uh what do you
think about that is attention
is a spotlight and
uh awareness is a floodlight
and so having awareness of the overall
relationship with the other person
and seeing them for who they are not who
you
hope they will become who you think they
should
be yeah which by the way is toxic
behavior trying to change someone
that is a type of of violence sometimes
not
physical violence but the change you
know
it's violent the same way an earthquake
is violent
it's not physically harming you directly
although it can indirectly harm you
but it is forcing the change
upon you that is
that's frustrating and what it does then
that attention think about the word
attention
at tension and so if we're just paying
attention
to all of those things that drive us
crazy about the relationship of course
it's
bubbling up this tension inside us
as opposed to that awareness if there's
full
open-hearted awareness for the
relationship
then there's a type of respect but also
appreciation for the other person and if
you're able to get there
then you're able to truly understand
them and no matter what they do
they cannot harm you because who told
you that you're supposed to be
respected who told you that you're
supposed to be
loved no no you're not supposed to be
anything if someone loves you that's
fine if not that's fine
too but as ryan said back in the
corporate days
it was sort of like you know i'm gonna
force these people to be my friend
and it's like well if i'm forcing you to
be my friend
are you am i really your friend i
remember i was like so heartbroken one
time when
i thought you know this it was an
employee of mine too
like it wasn't even like we weren't even
like colleagues in the sense as
like he worked for me and i just
remember
i forget what i've asked him to do
something like to hang out or something
he's like no dude
he's like i don't he's like no i have my
own life at home
i just remember being like you do
what's that like right and so that's a
type of solipsism right solipsism says
i am the center of the universe and the
thing is we're all solipsistic in that
way because
we all in our heads unless we stop and
have that awareness
that we talked about a moment ago unless
we have
an open-hearted open-eyed awareness for
the world and the people and the things
around
us then all of a sudden it's all about
me
and i get it it makes sense because it's
my
attention is always emanating from my
consciousness it's me watching my
television looking at my phone reading
my book drinking my water and so of
course that's our point of view what
awareness does allows us to step back
and say
okay that's an illusion you call it the
illusion of self or
but it's an illusion that i
am the center of the universe and if you
realize that that's an illusion then all
of a sudden
the i am suffering or i am angry or i am
upset or i am tense is also an illusion
tense
attention is appearing anger is
appearing
and no one has permission to
make you angry you are making yourself
angry in every
relationship and it's really hard for us
to deal with that and even now like
sometimes people make me angry but do
they really
it's like if the rain comes through and
rains all over your picnic
ryan was the
rain angry or are you angry is the rain
upset or are you
upset well you made that decision
either consciously or unconsciously to
be upset
by it the world goes on with or without
your
reactive emotion to it and so
whoever told you that you are
whoever told you that you're supposed to
be respected
or loved or anything else no no those
are ingredients for a meaningful
relationship
but you also have to earn those
ingredients by
reciprocating well the best way to
reciprocate is to do it in advance
yeah can we talk about toxic
relationships what is a
a toxic relationship i have a loose
definition i want to talk to you about
because
i think this word is often sort of it's
been overused and
vapidized over the last decade or so we
see it all the time now talking about
toxic relationships but for me a toxic
relationship
is one that tries to change me
and or one that pressures me
so it's it's either abusive that's a
type of pressure uh it could be physical
abuse emotional abuse
or it can just be passive aggression
right that that is
that is also toxic behavior so i really
look at those three ingredients there's
some sort of of
abuse there is uh the passive aggressive
nature or
someone is trying to change me
unfortunately we try to change people
all the time yeah you know what that's
like ryan
that's like if uh say i go to the doctor
because i've got ulcers in my stomach
right and i'm like oh doctor can you
prescribe
some medicine for my neighbor for my
best friend because i have ulcers in my
stomach
and he'd be like yeah sure i'm like oh
great now i feel better because now i'm
giving him
i'm changing him with this medicine
well no no i need to look inward and
change whatever's going on
with me the prescription is not for
someone else i don't need to fix you
ryan i simply need to
readjust the way that i'm interacting
with the world
yeah i think for me a toxic relationship
is one that moves you further away
from tranquility than it does bring you
towards it so
you know i mean relationships are there
to help you be
more tranquil oh i don't know that i
agree with that let's talk about this to
help you live
a more meaningful life i think your life
should certainly fulfill you
yeah so but and i think fulfillment will
bring you closer to tranquility
but the question is when you're around
someone do they take you further away
from tranquility
or are they on the journey with you
towards tranquility i'm not saying
relationships in general are
yeah i i don't know what words i use
that you disagreed with but
um but but that's ultimately what i'm
trying to say yeah another way to say
that is like think about that us box
yes you know if someone is just taking
the us box is
uh something that two parties in a
relationship
give and take from yes because we're not
just in relationships to give if we
said that we would just be lying to
ourselves right there are things we take
we also feel used
exactly so and you got to look at that
us box
um are you uh are you giving
or i'm sorry is is the other party
mostly taking from that us box
and if what they're giving again if what
they're giving is bringing you closer to
tranquility great
but ultimately when someone takes too
much their their burden on your life
they're not
yeah they're not a positive influence
yeah sure in fact i
heard who did i hear say this recently
oh it's in this uh during our added
value segment there is this uh
documentary i'm going to talk about one
of the the the people in the documentary
said
uh someone said every relationship is 50
50.
and his wife correct them said every
relationship is 80 20.
and i opine that by saying i think
that's more true but it's 80 20 for both
people
and meaning like that us box there are
times where you're going to contribute
80
it's there's never parody it's never 50
50 in just about anything
or if it is it's for such a short sliver
of time eventually
it that parody gets out of alignment and
that's okay
a uh in fact a lot of people use things
we give a definition for love
we talk about the fourth definition in
the dictionary it's a tennis term
and that tennis term is a score of
zero meaning there isn't a ledger there
isn't a
a a barometer for a measuring stick for
love if i am
if i am contributing 50 to the
relationship then i love you that's not
what love is
that's contribution which is different
from love now love will inspire you to
contribute beyond yourself right
and and that's a beautiful thing it will
it will inspire you to do
a lot of things to care to respect to to
tolerate to appreciate not just
the people that you love so-called love
or
really like when we say we love someone
we often mean we like them
or even more so that we desire them or
desire their validation
that's not love either desire is a
completely different thing from love and
and attachment often gets in the way of
our ability
to love openly and free freely
and i would say that many of our
relationships if not most of our
relationships
disrupt our especially in the
traditional western society
those relationships ryan they they
disrupt our tranquility
they think about to all of the
relationships in your 20s
the vast majority of them were
constantly just interrupting the peace
disturbing the peace yeah and and so
that can be toxic and it's not that
anyone has an intention
to harm you but if they are constantly
disturbing your peace
then well there are ways to navigate
that yeah i do want to talk to you about
that on
the maximal episode this thursday but
first ryan we got
what yeah we got a bunch of voicemail
comments and insights from our listeners
hello i'm justina from baltimore
i often hear the question about how to
get your spouse involved so i wanted to
share
my story my boyfriend and i have been
living together since november of 2006
and i found minimalism in 2018
after that time i made the effort to
really go through my belongings and
figure out what was actually
valuable while bagging up items for
goodwill
he told me how proud he was of me
for decluttering and finally getting rid
of my storage unit
i thanked him and told him how i only
wish
i made the time to do it sooner then i
told him if he wanted to go through his
items
i could wait to go to goodwill tomorrow
you know this was my
moment to finally talk to him about
minimalism and
asking him to get rid of his stuff
and he looked at me blatantly
and said what stuff would i get rid of i
don't really have any stuff
choking back my frustration i asked him
what did he mean
and he responded to me by when you moved
in
i gave up a lot of stuff to make room
for you i let go
some things i thought were really
important and even some of my father's
belongings
your place was a lot bigger and cheaper
and you gave that up to make me feel
more comfortable and for my happiness so
most of things i have now
either have a lot of value or you gave
me as a gift
and i looked around i noticed most of
the stuff in our place
was my own and if i ever moved out
it would be really empty so my point
being
is to look around your place is it
really his stuff
in the way or is it your clutter is it
your decorations and your
mentos making you feel claustrophobic
would you with a place do you share ever
be empty if you left
my other idea is to ask yourself the
dust
my boyfriend always gets sidetracked and
starts going through his stuff
while trying to adjust everything
so even though he doesn't have much to
get rid of
at least he still actively goes through
and cleans his own belongings
hi josh and ryan this is michelle from
west lafayette indiana
i just wanted to leave a comment
regarding the digital clutter episode
episode 173 which was awesome by the way
there was a question about feeling guilt
when taking people off social media
unfriending unfollowing or what have you
once in a blue moon i take a radical
approach
and delete my profile altogether now i
realize this won't be everyone's
favorite idea
however i've realized over time that the
people who matter most to me will friend
me again or vice versa
it's also nice to take what i consider a
deep breath
or maybe even a detox from that
particular social media site
again i realize that this is not
everyone's cup of tea
but it might be worth considering all
right y'all we got a bunch more
questions
this week some amazing questions bravo
podcast sean
about decluttering friendships about
relationships about toxicity
about so much more the minimalists.com
support if you want to listen to that
this thursday real quick for right here
right now here's one thing that's going
on in the life of
the minimalists since we're talking
about decluttering
friendships one thing that we're going
to talk about on
the maximum episode this week is all
right well what do we do
to find new empowering supportive
relationships in our life people who
share similar interests or
the same values as us especially
identifying
those foundational values and the
structural values and finding people who
are
like-minded or at least open-minded and
ryan and i have
founded a place who that has well
connected a whole lot of people tens of
thousands of people at this point
and we don't want anything from you you
can just head on over to minimalist.org
there's a hundred free local meetup
groups we started this in
2014 right yeah uh we were out until
yeah
it was 2014. and we um we went on tour
and we left behind these free local
meetup groups in 100 different cities
there's also an online city that's
thriving
thousands and thousands of people who
are sharing stories about decluttering
about careers about letting go of
relationships and marriages about
entering new relationships so finding
open-minded or like-minded people over
there at minimalist.org
you can connect with some folks over
there for added value this week ryan
what do you got for us this documentary
you're going to really enjoy it it's
uh by a guy named lance oppenheim
it's called some kind of heaven it takes
place in
the villages in florida have you ever
heard of the villages
what city is that in it's it's its own
city oh the villages is the name of the
city yeah
and so it is like its own town it's the
largest retirement community in america
it might be the largest retirement
community in the world
wow there's 130 000 people in one
retirement community wow and
it's this fascinating look and what i
realized while i was watching this film
is it's called some kind of heaven now
to some people it looks like a total
hell yeah being it's like this
the stepford picture of retirement
but for some people it actually is
heaven and so
you're finding people who are these sort
of like-minded or open-minded people
there who all
have similar values and they want to
share this communal experience together
it's not for everyone and what i
realized when i watched this film
and how beautiful it is and this sort of
social commentary that
it lays out i wouldn't do it justice
describing the whole thing i don't want
to give away certain aspects but
it follows around these different people
in the villages
some of them are elated i mean wonderful
they're like dancing singing it's like
they're reliving their college days
so happy to be there yes and there are
other people who are
miserable and isolated even though
they're around all these people
dude that's such a it's an interesting
like
almost a metaphor for one man's heaven
is another man's hell
exactly yeah so this is some kind of
heaven you can find it wherever you
rent films on the dsps they call it the
digital
streaming platforms we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like
what relationships have josh and ryan
personally decluttered recently
how can you declutter family
relationships
when do relationships have an expiration
date how do you make new friends in your
30s
and 40s surprised that question came up
several times ryan really and how do i
tactfully but
firmly decline social invitations plus a
million more questions
for the minimalist if you want to hear
all that join us on the minimalist
private podcast this week visit
theminimalists.com support to subscribe
and get your personal link
so that our private podcast plays in
your favorite podcast
app you know we're building a new studio
right now and thanks to our patrons
uh we're actually doing i mean it's
going to be stunning you're going to
enjoy it no longer we're going to be in
this temporary space i can't wait to get
into
the new studio yeah make it beautiful i
was just there this morning with podcast
sean and jordan no more we were
taking some measurements looking at
sound panels and a bunch of other stuff
it's going to look
gorgeous thank you for your support oh
by the way if you are one of our private
podcast supporters you also get access
to all of our archives over there
at no additional charge you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram
at the minimalists come to one of our
live podcast shows
visit the minimalists.com tour to find a
city near you
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast
email a voice memo to podcast at the
minimalists.com
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com you'll also receive
any new minimalist writings that we
publish for
free and if you leave here today with
just one message
let it be this love people and use
things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it
bye